we actually have some good news to start
with today obviously this is a context
of
lots of really bad news but it seems as
though dr anthony fauci's completely
outrageous in adversarial relationship
with the white house
is going to be repaired the day that
president-elect joe biden is sworn in
just six and a half weeks from now
because we've learned that joe biden
spoke to dr fauci
and has first and foremost confirmed
that dr fauci
joe biden wants dr fauci to stay in his
role at the
nih as the head um essentially the
the the head of of fighting pandemics as
the case effectively is
in the united states and in addition to
this joe biden has offered dr anthony
fauci
the role of chief medical advisor to the
white house
and dr fauci says that he accepted this
offer on the spot
here is video of anthony fauci being
interviewed on nbc by savannah guthrie
they also spoke about a hundred day
masking campaign which uh joe biden has
already
asked dr fauci about and i want to talk
about that
as well so let's take a look at this
clip joe biden said in an interview
yesterday
on his inauguration he's going to ask
americans
to wear a mask for a hundred days he
said just 100 days
not forever is that enough or do you
feel like that might put an artificial
time limit
on how long people may need to be
wearing masks
no no i he didn't mean it that way i
spoke to him about that what he wants he
just wants to get and it's a good idea
uniform he's saying hey folks trust me
everybody for a hundred days now it
might be that after that we still
gonna need it but he just wanted
everybody for a commitment for a hundred
days
and i discussed that with him and i told
him i thought that was a good idea
he also said he when he spoke to you he
asked you to continue in your role which
you've had under six presidents
but also to serve as his chief medical
advisor
uh will you do that did you say yes
oh absolutely i said yes right on the
spot yeah we have to hope
that the combination of the vaccine
starting to roll out although likely
a bit of a slower rollout than we would
like
combined with sanity entering the white
house combined with hopefully better
treatments becoming available
we are hoping that this will give us a
much better march than we are likely to
see in january and february
and then hopefully this will give us a
better second quarter of 2021 than we
are likely to see
in the first quarter of 2021 and then
hopefully we will have a better second
half of 2021
than what the first half will be but
let's talk
briefly about this hundred day mask
thing
i talked about this yesterday during
during a live stream a little bit
this is already being framed as some
kind of right-wing
authoritarian nightmare police state
where joe biden is deploying
federal troops to force people to wear
masks now i want to remind you
the authoritarian nightmare is trump and
trump's leaving it was
trump who used the military for domestic
law enforcement
and sent the military into protests that
was authoritarian
it's trump who claims he won an election
that he lost
that's authoritarian it's trump who has
been attacking
a free press and attacking individual
journalists that's authoritarian and i
could go on
joe biden can't actually affect
a mask mandate don't forget this when we
hear about
joe biden will ask all americans to wear
a mask
that's literally what it will be he will
ask americans to wear a mask
he can also and will ask governors
to push mask wearing and put in place
mask mandates
at least from the standpoint of commerce
and businesses
joe biden cannot legally put in place a
mass mandate so everybody's saying
the mass mandate he will put in is
authoritarian
he will not because he cannot put in
place a mask mandate now lots of people
will ignore it
hopefully many won't and we'll be able
to work together to reduce
the number of cases and the number of
deaths as we start to
vaccinate people hopefully as soon as a
week from today
but the big story is dr fauci staying on
and getting a bigger role government
living in reality is going to come back
we really need that desperately we also
need to be revering the doctors that are
spending their careers
trying to keep people healthy under
trump dr fauci
started to need full-time armed security
for himself and for his family this is
not normal
that's insanity there are very sick
people in this country that made
armed security a necessity for dr fauci
we have to reverse that now now you
might be wondering
why would joe biden do this isn't joe
biden worried
and jealous that anthony fauci might end
up with a higher approval rating than
joe biden
and the answer is no we're not worried
about that joe biden is not going to
uh determine which doctors he hires
based on whether they have higher or
lower approvals
remember donald trump complaining at a
rally
and at press briefings that somehow
fouchy has a higher approval
rating than trump uh has we've had uh
terrible luck really uh
it's really dr fauci's bad luck when we
needed him the most and not that we
didn't need him during ebola
not that we didn't need fouchy during
hiv and sars we did
but when we needed fouchy the most
during a global hundred year pandemic
we have a president who doesn't listen
to fauci
and actually attacks fauci to such a
degree that fauci needs armed security
it's truly insane
the good news is that at least this
aspect
of the insanity of this administration
is going to be reversed
one of our sponsors today is helix sleep
and it's a sponsor
i'm thrilled about because i sleep on a
helix mattress at home
and it's just the perfect mattress one
of the best things about helix is
you don't have to guess which mattress
do i need which one will be good for me
you take their famous sleep quiz on
their website you tell them your body
type
your sleeping position your back pain
issues you might have
and they will pair you with a mattress
that will be perfect for you
i took the sleep quiz the mattress they
suggested was exactly what i needed i
often get too hot at night the mattress
keeps me cool
it's not too soft it's not too firm the
texture is right
and i've just been getting way better
sleep you only buy a mattress
every decade or so don't get stuck with
something that's not perfect for you and
all helix mattresses come with a 10-year
warranty
and they'll even come to your house and
pick it up within a hundred days
if you don't love it but i think you
will all of my viewers will get up to
200
off your order and you'll get two super
premium pillows
for free when you go to the link right
underneath this video